what's going on guys this is Rob and
what I'm gonna try to do here is make
sense of the entire 2015 summer event
that Marvel's been talking about I'm
gonna try to give it to you guys in a
way to where you can walk away from this
video understanding exactly what's going
on or at least as much as everybody else
does
so what we need to do is we basically
need to establish the concept of the
Marvel timeline we need to talk about
what all this means all right so what
I've done here is I've made this little
timeline here in Photoshop and what
we're gonna do is we're gonna
systematically go through here and we're
gonna highlight important dates in the
history of Marvel's continuity so the
first thing is the 1960s
alright the 1960s is when you see Stan
Lee Jack Kirby and Steve Ditko
between these three people they create
the most prominent characters that have
existed in Marvel Comics The Incredible
Hulk Iron Man Thor spider-man the
Fantastic Four the Avengers the x-men so
on and so forth these are the people
that have been created in the 1960s but
the other thing as if the 1960s
established a shared continuity prior to
the 1960s there wasn't a shared
continuity characters existed in what
would be referred to as their own
reality their own continuity in the
1960s Thor crossed over with Iron Man
and the 1960s a Fantastic Four crossover
with the x-men so on and so forth this
is when we saw groups like The Avengers
come into existence all right what we do
now is we jump to 1981 and the reason
why we jump to 1981 specifically is
because this is when Marvel launches the
Days of Future past this has been
Marvel's most successful alternate
reality story to date now when I say
successful I mean in the sense of
fanfare and popularity among historians
and comic-book readers the Days of
Future past gave us a timeline whereby a
mystique led by the Brotherhood of Evil
Mutants had traveled traveled to a
meeting with Charles Xavier
they were McTaggart and Senator Robert
Kelley during this meeting the
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants killed all
three killed Charles Xavier Senator
Kelly and more McTaggart live on TV in
an effort to instill fear of mutants in
the eyes of humanity the result of this
was that humans feared them but in turn
they rebooted The Sentinel program but
the suno program became autonomous it
became self-aware and it is
because mutants are an extension of the
evolution of humans they have to control
both mutants and humans and so they
enslave them both and became very
oppressive now Marvel had to find a way
out they had to find a way to fix this
problem and so what they did is they
said that Rachel summers is going to
send the mine of Kitty Pryde into the
past Kitty Prydz mind goes into the the
body of her younger self in the past she
warns the x-men the x-men are able to
stop the assassination of Senator Robert
Kelley more McTaggart and and Charles
Xavier
but the marvel encounters a problem and
Marvel says if this was able to happen
if they were able to stop the
assassination and how was it that Kitty
Pryde mind was able to go back into the
past in the first place and stop an
assassination that never happened they
created a paradox and so what Marvel did
is they made the data-feature past an
alternate reality they made it a totally
separate continuity from what we had
seen with with with this particular
circumstance and this is what Marvel's
going to do any and every time there is
any kind of an event that alters reality
and the mainstream continuity if that
reality is altered Marvel's going to go
back and rectify it
and then that altered reality is going
to become an alternate reality of its
own it's going to branch off and become
something totally different now
sometimes we'll see these realities come
to an end in that story sometimes we
won't and we left to wonder whether or
not that reality still continues on a
lot of times we won't be given an answer
to that question the Days of Future past
is a perfect example here now what we do
here is we jumps in 1983 and the reason
we jump to 1983 is because in Marvel UK
where Marvel was trying to branch out
into the United Kingdom with comic books
we had seen what was referred to as the
Captain Britain core this was basically
a group that was a variant of the Green
Lantern Corps from DC Comics a man Brian
Braddock and in Britain fought under the
guise of Captain Britain but he was one
of many from alternate realities in 1983
Marvel for the first time would ever use
the designation earth-616 referring to
the mainstream earth continuity and so
this is when we learned that the
mainstream Marvel continuity where
everything has taken place since the
1960s is earth-616 from this point going
forward mama would start using numerical
designations to different
between earth-616 and other continuities
now what this does is it leads us to 12
years later this leaves us at 2011 2012
when Marvel launches the incursians then
what had happened here is Jonathan
Hickman and Marvel had gotten together
and they had decided that basically the
entire multiverse needed to be pruned
they had to do some housecleaning here
there were way too many alternate
realities some of which we had seen
finished some of which we had seen come
to an end
others were presumably still going on
they were just kind of left in the air
and we had no idea and so what Jonathan
Hickman did is he basically introduced
us to the idea of alternate realities
and we saw more realities and we had
ever seen than in any other point in
Marvel history what this did is it
allowed Jonathan Hickman to do two
things it allowed him to give us
realities that we had always wanted to
see but it also allowed him to get rid
of realities that didn't need to exist
now what this is doing is this leads
into the 2015 summer event and what this
does is it basically allows a Marvel to
kill off all the unnecessary realities
it allows them to continue or I guess to
conclude stories that had been left
hanging but it allows Marvel to bring us
a continuation of all the realities that
we had enjoyed but we had never seen a
conclusion of and so what Marvel is
going to do here is as far as they've
told us the last incursion that is to
say the last two planets that crash into
each other are going to belong to the
earth-616 continuity and the Ultimate
Universe then what's gonna happen is the
universe's are going to crash into one
another and they're both going to be
destroyed presumably this is going to
lead to a formation of a place called
battle world and what this is going to
do is allow Marvel to take all their
most popular stories they have ever done
and they're going to throw them all on
this one world now this is where things
get sticky and this is where things get
a little confusing what we don't know
here is how much contact characters are
going to have we know they're going to
fight eventually or I guess initially we
know that there may have some conflicts
as time goes on but we don't know if
Miles Morales as spider-man from the
Ultimate Universe is going to be
fighting crime in the same city as Peter
Parker as spider-man we don't know if
Gwen Stacy is going to be an existence
in the same universe as spider-man we
don't know if these things are going to
play off this way we don't know if
they're going to exist this way all we
know is that things are just going to
play
in such an interesting way that most
likely we're gonna have to buy the
individual books and so on and so forth
but what this banner world is is
Marvel's new continuity from this point
going forward or when the or when the
battle world actually starts there will
be no more alternate realities there are
no more alternate timelines there's
nothing left hanging out there this is
it and so what we can do is we can say
that this battle world is Marvel issue
number one this is Marvel world number
one this is continuity number one this
is Marvel basically starting all over
again but the difference here is that
the continuity of various characters
that have existed in the past their
origins still remain and that's why I
say this is a little weird again we're
waiting on information from Marvel we're
waiting for them to fill in the blanks
and give us more info on what's going on
with that being said we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly